Це був один з найгірших моментів в її житті:
неподалік цього місця чоловік, якого Семмі Вудхауз любила, пригрозив вбити її.
Це сталося на схилах поблизу її рідного Ротергема, коли їй було лише 15 років.
Він підвів мене на край і сказав, що скине вниз.
Я думала, він мене вб'є. Я дуже перелякалася.
Потім він поклав мене на багажник автомобіля і зайнявся зі мною сексом, наче нічого не трапилося.
Пам'ятаю, що я просто лежала і плакала. Я почувалася, наче вмерла.
Лише через кілька років Семмі змогла порвали зі своїм кривдником.
Зараз вона допомагає іншим жертвам.
Щонайменше півтори тисячі дітей стали жертвами секс-експлуатації
у Ротергемі протягом майже двадцяти років.
Слідство проти ґвалтівників досі триває.
На думку Семмі, місцева влада та поліція до останнього применшували масштаби злочинів,
бо більшість банд складалася з вихідців з Пакистану - і ніхто не хотів бути звинуваченим у расизмі.
Люди ставилися до нас, як до непотребу.
Нас вважали дітьми-повіями, нас так і називали, що, звичайно ж, було неправильно.
Ми були дітьми, яких ґвалтували.
Міська рада Ротергема оприлюднила заяву про те,
що таке більше не повинно повторитися.
Проте у пакистанській громаді дискусія щодо того, що сталося - триває й досі.
Дехто реагує дуже вороже.
Мохамед Шафік відчув це на собі, коли почав говорити,
що багато пакистанців не поважають білих жінок та дівчат.
Люди не хочуть говорити про це, вони кажуть,
що подібні дискусії на користь правих радикалів.
Але тепер, коли почалися судові процеси, люди визнали,
що це проблема, якою треба впритул зайнятися.
Семмі Вудхауз не хоче жити минулим, але каже:
було б краще, якби цю проблему визнали значно раніше.
Факт полягає в тому, що вони закривали на це очі,
не хотіли, щоб їх називали расистами,
але натомість злочинці відчули свою безкарність.
У випадку Семмі її кривдник нині у в'язниці, але сотні інших - досі на свободі.